♪.
>> THE PROBLEM WAS THE REFUGEE
LAW WAS WORKING ON --
[INAUDIBLE].
BORDER WITH YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE COULDN’T DO TWO THINGS AT
ONCE.
LAWRENCE: JOE BIDEN FINALLY
ADMITTING THERE IS A CRISIS AT
BORDER AS HE DEFENDS INITIAL
MOVES ON REFUGEE CAM.
WILL: AFTER 26 DAYS, 2DAYS
WITHOUT A PRESS CONFERENCE FOR
KAMALA HARRIS SUPPOSEDLY IN
CHARGE OF THE BORDER SURGE.
JOE BIDEN CALLED ON HER TO FIX
IT.
WE’LL SEE.
JEDEDIAH: OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS
SHE NEVER SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE
ROLE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, "THE HILL"
MEDIA COLUMNIST, JOE CONCHA IS
WITH US TO EXPLAIN.
JOE, WHY SHIPMENT SHE HAVE
GOTTEN THIS JOB TO BEGIN WITH?
>> JED THERE ARE SEVERAL
REASONS.
I WOULD NOT CALL THIS A CRISIS
BUT IS A CATFY.
PER OF THE PASS STATEMENTS
SHOULD HAVE DISQUALIFIED HER.
SHE COMPARED I.C.E. TO THE KKK.
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS SHOULD
BE LEGAL AND SAID THIS AS A
CANDIDATE AND IF THOSE ARE YOUR
POSITIONS HOW DO YOU FIX A
SITUATION LIKE THIS?
IT IS PAINFULLY APPARENT YOU
WILL SEE NOT KAMALA HARRIS AT
THE BORDER.
YOU WILL SEE DETROIT LIONS AT
THE SUPER BOWL.
AS LAWRENCE AND WILL KNOW, YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE NEVER SEEN THE
LIONS THERE.
SHE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON HER POLICY
POSITIONS.
EVEN THOUGH SHE IS IN CHARGE OF
THE DIPLOMACY SIDE OF IN TERMS
OF GUATEMALA, NICARAGUA AND
MEXICO SHE HAS NOT TRAVELED
THERE.
DON’T TELL ME BECAUSE OF COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
AT LAST CHECK SHE IS FULLY
VACCINATED.
THE CDC SAYS IT IT IS FINE FOR
HER TO TRAVEL TO MEET PEOPLE
INDOORS WITHOUT A MASK.
THAT.
WILL: SOUNDS LIKE A SEGMENT ON
THE WILL CAIN PODCAST.
WHICH GOES TO THE SUPER BOWL
FIRST.
KAMALA HARRIS AS YOU POINTED OUT
HAS A SHIFT SHOWING NO INTEREST
IN A SECURE BORED, LEADS TO THE
QUESTION DO THEY WANT TO FIX IT?
>> THAT IS THE QUESTION, RIGHT.
THINK ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS
PERSONALLY.
THERE ARE MORE THAN A FEW PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE THAT SHE WILL BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IN 2024 AND
NOT JOE BIDEN.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT AN 80
SOMETHING JOE BIDEN.
MAYBE HE WANTED TO SERVE ONE
TERM.
HE HASN’T COMPLETELY, TOTALLY
DEFINITELY SAID HE WILL RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN.
PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT, OKAY, IN
TERMS OF YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
KAMALA HARRIS WHAT DID YOU DO
WITH THE BIGGEST RESPONSIBILITY
YOU HAD AS VICE PRESIDENT IN
TERMS OF FIXING OUR BORDER
CATASTROPHE?
AND SHE WON’T PROBABLY HAVE MANY
ANSWERS BECAUSE AGAIN YOU LOOK
AT THESE FACILITIES, DANGEROUSLY
OVERCROWDED.
YOU HEAR REPORTS NOW OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT OF YOUNG GIRLS.
THIS IS THE SAME CANDIDATE IN
HARRIS, BY THE WAY, WHO COMPARED
THESE FACILITIES THAT YOU’RE
CURRENTLY SEEING, NOT SEEING
BECAUSE THERE IS MEDIA BLACKOUT,
PICTURES THAT GET OUT,
CONCERNING BABIES IN CAGES SHE
CALLED IT.
SHE IS NOT DOING SO MUCH TO HELP
THE BABIES IN CAGES.
THIS WILL BE THE SIGNATURE
FAILURE AND ANY REPUBLICAN THAT
RUNS AGAINST HER LIKE RON
DESANTIS OR EVEN DONALD TRUMP
WILL BE QUICK TO POINT THIS OUT.
SHE WILL NOT HAVE ANSWERS TO
TALK ABOUT.
LAWRENCE: DID THEY REALLY NEED
TO APPOINT SOMEONE TO DO THIS
JOB?
MAYORKAS, HE KNOWS.
HE WAS A DEPUTY BEFORE.
JOE BIDEN KNOWS.
WEIGH WAS A VICE PRESIDENT.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY FEED TO DO
TO GET A HANDLE ON THIS.
ARE THEY JUST REFUSING TO.
>> IT SEEMS THEY ARE.
I THINK MAYORKAS IS SET UP TO BE
THE FALL GUY, LAWRENCE, POINT TO
HIM, HE IS IN CHARGE OF DHS.
THIS IS HIS RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THEY HOPE
THIS WILL GO AWAY EVENTUALLY.
HERE WE ARE IN APRIL.
THE WEATHER WILL GET WARMER IN
MAY, THIS WILL ONLY GET WORSE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A MEDIA
DEMANDING ACCOUNTABILITY HERE.
THAT MEANS ACCESS TO ALL
FACILITIES, ACCESS TO ALL BORDER
PATROL AGENTS.
INTERESTING COVERING ON MAJOR
PLACES LIKE THE EVENING NEWS,
THEY’RE STILL GET 25 MILLION
VIEWERS A NIGHT ADD UP ABC, CBS,
NBC.
FOX IS COVERING IT.
CNN AND MSNBC DO HAVE AN
INTEREST.
UNTIL "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
"NEW YORK TIMES," EVERYONE GETS
IN UNISON LIKE WITH DONALD TRUMP
THEY CALL A CRISIS, I THINK THEY
CAN GET AWAY WITH IT, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ACCOMPLICE IT MEDIA
NOT INTERESTED IN SOLVING THE
PROBLEM OR COVERING IT.